*yawns*
It's 3 AM and we're going to the airport
Lets go!
VLOG TIME!
*Humming airplane sounds*
You forget that 4 AM exists
If you haven't been up in a while at this hour
We're going to
*MARRAKECH*
That's right we're visiting Marrakech everyone
It's pretty interesting so far
It's really stingy!
Someone just grabbed Marzia and started putting like the tattoos thing
Yeah she was just like *pulling hands*
And I was like
NO NO NO (yamete senpai)
And she was like
uGhrUghrAhhHaHeE
I leave you for 2 seconds
and looked away
And Marzia's just gets abducted
[Music]
It's a bit of a culture shock
Marzia: Yeah
But
It's kinda cool
It's beautiful!
Marzia, I dare you to go up to it.
*Gets told to not film oof*
Oh sorry
Everything is different here
you get a coke and
you get a surprise as well
Nice 'lil surprise here
on the pizza
*eating intensifies*
[Music]
I can get a
PewDiePie haircut here
Do you see it?
Yeah go back to the
hEhhHEEhhE
[Motorcycle sounds]
What's that?
that's great
There's just something going on
literally everywhere
Said no about 500
-600 times so far
-oh yeah
hEheHeH
I need to figure out how to say it in their language
'cause
No doesn't mean 'no' here
No means ah you, you still want
HeHehE
Why do they have mannequins everywhere?
Watch o what?
There's a wall
Marzia wants me to film it
Dude
there's a bird too
the birds are gonna come down and be like: "pay us"
You can't just film this wall
...look at that bird!
that's a massive bird
that's a big bird
big, big bird
look at that bird
these stuff everywhere
[sound of water]
[birds chirping]
look at that, beautiful
*SIGH*
the hotel is a bit of a contrast
from...
the outside *laughs*
so we got this trip from Marzia's parents
thank you very much
and brother, for uhhh ... wedding gift?
Marzia in background: "yes'
an early wedding gift
wow [chuckles]
cozy
Host: "Welcome to your room'
Marzia: "thank you"
host: "so here you have whatever you need: enveloppe, papers on the desk
so this is our room
this is our room tour
this is our bed
this is where we sleep
Pewds:"What were you doing?"
Marzia: "just you know -- yeah okay"
-Marzia: "what?!" -Pewds:"What? don't film!"
You didn't even show, we are right infront the swimming pool
very nice
and then he disappears
[pewds chuckles softly]
[both laughing]
Pewds: "you were scared, i saw you flinch"
listen I thought you were in here
this is a beautiful bathroom
and that's the tour, thanks guys
so you leave and the pool is right there!
very epic!
How do I look?
I see myself and I know I rock it
[relaxing music]
Whaddup kitty?
You find like these really random beautiful shots
Or Marzia did
And then you lean and look down and it's like 'oh okay'
I feel like if your -- if you filter
You can make this place look amazing
You just gotta know where to look
we just made our first succesful haggle
and we saved two pounds
you wanna be careful around corners here
Look at that, so pretty
I bought a can of pringles
And I didn't get swin-- swing-- swindled
Marzia: "nice"
Goodmorning
It's day two... We're sitting at this very lovely breakfast
Very fancy
today we're going to Saint-Laurent...
...museum
And then blue building
And it's gonna be epic
We're at the fancy tourist area now. I think at least- Is this the line?
oh-oh
it probably is
Oh no!
Okay, so that was just the first line, this is the second line
We found the back of the line
Amazing
We made it to the end guys... Unbelievable
that was a challenge but we made it through
here we are!
Look there's a bamboo forrest again!
We're back in Japan
Look at this, damn.
c'est magnifique
French, still got it!
[Music]
We found it!
*Zooming intensifies*
[Music]
So this garden was bought by a French painter
And then it was taken over by Yves Saint Laurent
And he restored it, with some other guy. That's why they're connected.
some general, I don't know!
He's the famous fashion designer, then I-don't-care
Whaddup, cat?
You don't like my bread?
aah, poor dog
go to the shadow you dummy
Alright we're going to Saint Laurent museum, excited!
Yeah x3 whaat?
Question mark, excited?
We already got our ticket, we can skip the lane, incredible!
the long line
There you go. Hello
Merci beaucoup! (very good french, Felix)
*awkward posing*
Alright, we're going to bubble café
It better has bubbles or else!
You sorta forget how crazy it is every time you go in to the hotel and then it is like 'oh yeah'
this is how it is
The bird's still there, chillin'
You can't really tell how big it is, big bird.Very large bird.
Big bird everyone
pretty good view!
I saw they updated tuber simulator and slickpea is now....
... He's a ghost
He lives on in tuber simulator
I found Joji, filthy frank
Doesn't he look like him?
I didn't know Joji was popular in Morocco, damn.
Ohh, look at the tiny cat!
Ohh
Look at this
People just trash their shit here
Because why not
I got nothing, I'm sorry
[Music]
It's Saturday but there's... Barely any people
It's pretty much what we hoped for, just a break from all the madness
There's a pirate ship!
Oh my god we went on the lamest slide and we get destroyed
Marzia her foot-- we went down this little kids slide and we both just shocked from it
I don't know. We looked at all the kids and they went so slow and then we just went-- I guess we're heavy
I don't think I'm ready for this
Oh my G--
Is it even open? Marzia: "yeah" "Goodluck!"
AAAAAAH
They said you can protect like this and I was like 'why' but now I understand
It hurts!
Oh!
It's happening
Oh my god!
You wanna go on that one?
Very chill
Is that the one that just opened?
We're about to do the most exciting ride of the century
Why? I can explain what it is
It's a bit random... To go to Marrakech
Just for a waterpark but I've never been to one so...
Why not?
Say that again Marzia.
It got two balls
That's the tip
Ewwww
We're on the boats! I smuggled the phone.
Hopefully they don't kick us out
What are you doin'? Oh yeah!
That's right
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get burnt, I'm sorry mom
I'm trying not to
Let go right fricking now or else!
(Felix has legs?????)
Haha, AAAAAAH, oh it's scary!
[Relaxing music]
We are having... Our...
... Proposal dinner
One year ago
Marzia:"And we're married"
Pewds: "No, we're not"
What is this?
Marzia: "It looks like-- it's a safety ring"
Do you guys like the Leonardo DiCaprio/Matt Damon haircut?
[Mellow music]
What?
Nani?
Damn, you burnt girl!
Mom is watching right now, I didn't get burned from the sun
Alright that's the end of the vlog
We're about to go on our private jet
And thank you Marrakech, it's been real
Like subscribe
and checkout merch
Have a great life (Thank you felix, you too. We love you <3)
see you later